welcome to this video new tactics
trainer session yeah this is the 1,800
level so I'm switching varying these
these levels let's take out some 1800
rated problems here um okay
we are black here in this position and
we recognize that bounce sipping and
also there might be some back ranked
issue for white but it's mostly of
course about the c-pawn we want to
promote the pawn the first move that
really comes to mind as Queen c3 yeah we
threatening c1 Queen what is white going
to do it probably only has Quincy one I
don't see any other move and then we
have a violent way too fast through the
pawn rook e1 check yeah distracting the
screen Queen e1 has to take and then we
promote and at the end we have two
queens so Queen c3 should be the end of
this that's not very that's not very
difficult we take the rook so we should
really look look at the other thing just
just briefly so this was routed to
Quincy three Quincy one being the
tougher defense and now it's some other
solution by the way sometimes I don't
think so
Rock Lee one is the good and simple way
to do it so that we had the f2 Queens
against Queen and rook
there is no nowhere try to defend this
forward okay next one oh that's funny
always cute this kind of situation with
two pieces or something against the
Queen
okay so what about this it feels like we
we might be able to win the Queen
somehow we are smoother with folks we
want Forks like Queen takes G - that's
not a form with the with the win this
kind of thing might be might be possible
okay so let's see how can we how can we
do this it's there Oh is there some some
made some meat and down no don't see
don't see it made ready
I guess it's about a couple of checks
right so night f1 check it must be a
check if we do this check he goes to the
fr we have night h3 check win the Queen
if he goes to g7 we have roped g3
winning the Queen as Queen G 3 that's 9
h5 with a fork that's a funny motif and
we have to check on f4 and we can put
this on the board this is the solution
and this is the relatively toughest one
where we have to give the check dogs
back and now Group g3 yeah so it was
about a fork yeah and there's always
always various folks in there we briefly
pull up the analysis board we see that
here if he goes to the fr we have this
it's simple if he goes to g7 we have
rook g3 which is the same thing that
happened in the in the main line that
that we had on the board earlier so not
not a very creative advise if you have a
knight look for Forks they are them okay
let's see you next one that looks that
looks dangerous
yeah this almost looks like a line from
little year Fisher so this is this
classic classic game yeah here we really
don't know any classic game but Fisher
we just need to meet the guy and we can
with Queen f4 I just put it on the board
g5 check just one move f4 just one move
and double check mate very important
double check yeah that would shake can
only be answered by King move the other
rooks are able to take both pieces
well technically but not really because
it's a double check
so very nice and yeah white really has
nowhere no way
algea if we put the net as this board on
again just briefly after the capture
King entry is a mate and king h4 is the
same meet so he has nothing else than
capturing the Queen and running right
into the mate as shown you on the border
okay the next one is this is interesting
yeah that's an interesting situation
here
yeah funny yeah this this night on this
night on g7 it's really really cute but
if we if we start if we start yet if we
consider the capture first like just has
has captured on on e4 if we consider to
take on you for what can happen after
that
yeah Bishop takes I guess with the main
thread on g2 ruk f2 is not helping then
twin see one is perpetual takes Bishop
takes bikini Oh Queen g3 and try to to
just defend the position maybe maybe
yeah
this also of course there is this this
possibility in the position let's say if
it's why if white could take on f8 yeah
my Queen c7 takes away the King takes
rook hey check Mookie and rook takes a
check media there are also those this
kind of made some in them in the
position hmm okay at the moment however
white is like it's not not threatening
much anyway
rookie - maybe still I think the de
Bishop takes in this winning I mean
Queen g3 let's never ever enough for
black but okay I guess it's something
with Queen takes afraid but I'm not
seeing it at the moment
I can play rooks I can play rook c5 but
Queen d3 where where is the win
hmm or is there let's say after move
like Queen d6s is there no defense to
queen of a diamond
we've a bit mystified especially because
I really don't see how D takes a bishop
takes is anything from like that's never
enough never but I guess it's not the
solution and it was very maybe maybe
this isn't so easy I don't know after it
takes Queen G 3
maybe D 3 this kind of stuff but I don't
say don't see how I'm winning this year
huh strange I mean 26 if we again
consider this move intending Queen evade
yeah with this made key he can play Roxy
eight maybe it's this is a big
difference yeah but I'm just too bad at
tactics what can I do I don't see I
don't see how this how I can do
something much better than taking in the
rook Queen Steve McQueen see five he
will trade Queens
I really would like to know how to win
here probably I'm just having an all-day
and don't do it I don't really see it I
really don't see it
Queen d6 Roxy and how is this winning
and is there I am I am I missing
I mean I'm dead as usual I'm totally
violating the candidates most principle
but still still takes Bishop Teague's or
is there some other other defense who is
it just that I mean come on I just take
the sisters in one sense now it really
it is just like that oh come on this is
a joke yeah I was thinking or what's the
big deal yeah yeah you see having d3 and
I'm not seeing it come on yeah you're
getting worried yeah because this is
just like the normal stuff and I mean I
was thinking I may be d3 and why has
thought that okay this is never going to
work but reott very yet so a bit of a
bit of a strange problem which probably
yeah I don't know I I just couldn't
couldn't believe that it is a simple
solution but it apparently is okay the
next one this really looks like we
should have a meteor come on
okay so it is it is not like Black has
lots of space for his King let's see oh
my god how we are going to do this it
looks like he has very little squares
like Queen g7 that's the first move that
comes to mind I think Queen g7 Bishop g7
rook f7
came to d6 ha where's the maid Knight b5
check King d5 King v5 and where is where
is the maid
Ruka for and c4 made next move as soon
as weird as it sounds I think this is
working
yeah I think this is working
maybe we have something something else
but Queen g7 Bishop g7 rook f7 check
King d6 Knight b5 check King D 5 c4
check his king e4 ok but we can do that
C for checking e4 rupee one is made ok
this is this is simpler so here we go
take my queen is something quicker ok
one maid is definitely enough so check
him and he only has 25 and okay we have
c4 check King e4 rook e1 maid was only
wondering ok Bishop rook F form it's
less good because of bishop takes less
good is worse because of bishop takes e5
so we really want want to give the
checks and get in this checkmate
okay I would have liked looking forward
to work but there is this stupid bishop
watch seven okay nice one oh this looks
like yeah white white to play and
probably find some checkmate hmm okay
yeah the first we look at checkers and
captures of course rook h6 looks very
tempting King takes h6 the screen g6
made so quickly spotted I think and if
we take on age six and he plays pawn
takes we have Knight f6 check King h8
Queen g8 mate nice
and Luke takes h6 King to g8 Knight f6
check King at seven Queen j6 made so
fire away this is the solution the
variation of the Arabian maids not with
the Queen on g8 okay next one oh it's
easy
mostly checks around okay again we have
the situation where it looks like a very
simple thing is happening I guess it
really is Bishop rook takes a for Bishop
takes and for Queen a one is a double
attack rook is hanging Bishop is hanging
again a typical situation there are news
pieces unprotected pieces the bishop and
the rook so black will lose one of them
and with it the game okay this does not
look much like there's a tactic possible
but maybe there is yeah it isn't this
our we just winning this this is poor
knight on c6 it looks nice on g6 but if
we think about Knight to be seven the
fiat night fianchetto queen is 7 we take
on c6 and white is doing not much maybe
it's making a sad face but I think this
is the solution the only and here we go
yeah that's really not much else to it
we just we just take this piece yeah you
know it to be seven queenie 7 we also
take and here it's a yeah here the white
queen is problem even getting trapped
with
ei to come okay so this was a case where
it's all about the uncoordinated
situation between the knight and the
Queen the knight is alone and stranded
okay okay so what is this
I mean if he gives check King D to Queen
takes d4
we're just winning with just winning the
night for for for nothing basically he
can go to we can go back to see one of
course
then we also have to check on e3 yeah
probably this is the solution here we
have the check on e3 at the end and then
we have night h5 because rook h 5g h v
g6 is not working because the Queen
hangs so probably this is it it's do or
do we have something something even even
simple I like a mate or or something I
really don't don't think so
Queen a3 check King me one there's
nothing we can just do this I mean don't
think that maybe here maybe here we can
we can consider Knight takes e4
definitely maybe this is even stronger
Knightly form yeah but if he takes
there's really no major I look after we
can even go to e3 that's stupid but we
can take on difference we take on before
he goes to e 1 we have to check on his 3
immediately
kingi to this Bishop b5 check if he goes
back to c1 ok you can argue that this is
not really a win young Queen III check P
moves Knight h5 because it's not not
immediately winning ok
but what if we take first king c1 and
after the check on a1 kingly to then
Knight takes e4 is this maybe winning
now we have this tons of checksum or is
it or is it rook c8 at the end yeah I
mean does this this is certainty right I
mean we can do this first and now think
think about it again my original idea
was Queen III check King moves Knight
age five and to the attack is stopped
but I mean we have two pieces and two
pawns to run our two pieces and one pawn
can struggle it's probably enough but
it's there is there something better if
we give the check again King D - I don't
see how how 94 for example wins takes
rook after - we just goes to e3 there is
no maid
I mean this is really enough Queenie
freon Oh am i stupid again like I'm not
seeing something very simple and now
yeah here maybe rook c8 even I thought
King b1 but okay rook c8 if he takes on
f6 Quincy 3 check King b1 Quincy - yeah
but this is just the draw right
there's no checkmate Knight h5 is very
good for black probably this is just
right I mean yeah I just really like
that yeah I was thinking it's that maybe
it's something more convincing but this
is this is a win I mean the problem is
that if we put up the end of this bond
at the end the problem is that white has
no a continuation now of the attack rook
takes h5
rook takes h5 and this is simply failing
due to this and this means that white
really has no no follow up well black
still can play with rook F rook c8 and
there should be six he can attack
further White's queen is basically
imprisoned on h6 so it is a winner I was
just thinking that maybe there is
something even even more crushing but
there wasn't okay next one okay so we
have quite some some firepower on f7
yeah and we need you to check or to
calculate the checks first what
immediately comes to mind is rook f7 we
have seven Bishop f7 96 check using the
pin
King g8 Queen g7 mate or look f7 Bishop
796 Jack Keaney 897 check wins the Queen
that might be the solution
look f7 King 8 is this in any way
possible to to hold I know II can take
it 7 that Queen g7 okay so this is the
solution I guess but briefly let's just
check okay
it is really enough and here we will
take the Queen okay so there was nothing
nothing tricky tricky in this one really
we need to check the forcing moves first
like here group takes f7 check and they
immediately with the series of checks
lead to decisive material gains okay the
next one okay that's funny so what is
what is this actually if we take on g4
with the night but what exactly is the
problem isn't this just a piece you take
what the Queen you will take on e5 I
mean I can't just take it I'm not quite
sure what this is but it was simple
Queen takes d5 is less convincing we
just take we just take this Bishop and
and and good yeah it's it's a bit this
position is a bit bit
yeah really changing maybe cuz it's so
weird
okay just next one please so we are
black
why'd Rhea here watch it has some
amazingly badly placed pieces the Queen
on a for the rook was before but black
has an excellent excellent coordination
but how exactly are we going to win hmm
yeah if this is the case I was the first
thing that I thought of is luck what
about rook F 3 and then 94 and so on and
then I thought about wait okay it's not
a real game kind of approach but this is
an 1800 problem it shouldn't be is so
sophisticated and then I spotted that we
can just attack this unlucky look on be
formed and white is just going to resign
the ruckus is just gone can take on b5
and then we take on b5 and fork night
and queen so a total of total win for
black funny up and yeah in any way very
very logical because this is the
terrible piece on before okay yeah this
is this is a case where it's a dramatic
position yeah lots of stuff is hanging
our queen is attacked yes some probably
taking on e4 and yeah I'm probably
hoping for de for Queen G for this kind
of desperado counter-attack but we need
to calculate checks first and we only
have one check rook g6 and this is some
in fact immediately decisive look g6
check HT 6 g 6 27 made simple so he has
to take with the airport and then we
need to calculate the most forcing moves
first and here Queen h8 is super forcing
as the King has to take and then look f8
mate so
got a very nice sequence of moose that
leads to checkmate yeah something that
can be seen relatively quickly if we
check the most forcing moves first with
the highest priority okay the next one
okay so we are what we are exchange down
here but I wonder what exactly is the
big problem here if we just go night b3
we're going to win a whole rook right or
the Queen if he moves along then we are
even appears AB now okay this time I'm
not going to wait here for for three
minutes and ask myself if there's
something different or better or
whatever this is just winning winning in
the house here we are Peter Pan so
Knight B 3 is just attacking this focal
point on c5 this ruckus in the deadly
crossfire and will get lost completely
not even for some material just the
whole rook okay so a final one this is
again not looking good
Wow do that this is a this is a very
quick pawn
and okay to be honest the typical case
where you really have some some brain
brain blockade or whatever of course I
saw night a six immediately as the thing
to check
yeah night a six to threat and ninety
seven mate blacks King has no squares
this is the first big point of this and
if we get the check on c7 in with the
night is the mate and night a six Roxy
897 check rooks e7 rook t8 made but then
I was thinking I mean there's a one and
it's a pin if there's a queen and so on
but this is like total nonsense as we it
just wins yeah I can do this this
desperate sacrifice but it's just a win
another thing that I was briefly
thinking about if we go to analysis
board just briefly the mood that also
looks funny
besides night a six-night a six we do
this 96 this also looked funny the same
idea basically but here there's route k5
as a defense and here that's route a six
I was briefly thinking about that does
this kind of thing because as f7 made a
but black him just take everything here
and at the end win with a one it's it's
useless before night a six
it's just winning the thing the thing
anyway but yeah tonight is six it's
looking like the same idea might work as
well but it's not okay this was this was
funny I hope you enjoyed the session of
this 1800 read the problems
and yeah more of the chess on tactics
trainer next week thanks for watching